HOUSE ON MONDAY FOR A
CELEBRATION BEFORE TAKING OFF
FOR NEW ORLEANS.
>>> CONGRESS HAS LEFT WASHINGTON
FOR THE WEEKEND, SEEMINGLY NO
CLOSER TO A RESOLUTION OF THE
SHUTDOWN THAN WHEN IT BEGAN
THREE FULL WEEKS AGO.
MIKE EMANUEL IS ON A VERY QUIET
CAPITOL HILL TONIGHT.
GOOD EVENING.
>> Reporter: GOOD EVENING, BRET.
THERE ARE NO NEGOTIATIONS TAKING
PLACE.
CONGRESS IS GONE FOR THE
WEEKEND.
OTHERS ARE LEFT WITH ANXIETY AND
UNCERTAINTY.
>> TODAY, 800,000 FEDERAL
EMPLOYEES WILL NOT RECEIVE THEIR
FIRST PAYCHECK OF THIS NEW YEAR.
>> Reporter: 21 DAYS INTO A
PARTIAL SHUTDOWN AND REALITY IS
HITTING HOME FOR THOUSANDS OF
FEDERAL WORKERS.
TODAY, THE HOUSE APPROVED A
SENATE PLAN TO PROVIDE THEM WITH
THEIR MISSED PAY.
NOT UNTIL THE PARTIAL SHUTDOWN
ENDS.
BACK PAY WHEN THE GOVERNMENT
OPENS.
IT DOESN'T DO YOU MUCH GOOD IF
YOU HAVE BILLS THAT COME NEXT
WEEK.
>> AMONG THOSE THAT ARE NOT
GETTING PAID, THE PEOPLE ON THE
FRONT LINE OF THE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION FIGHT.
>> THE BRAVE MEN AND WOMEN THAT
ARE ON THE GROUND EVERY DAY
SECURING OUR BORDER SHOULD GET
PAID.
>> WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP STANDING
FIRM ON FUNDING TO BUILD A
BORDER WALL, FRUSTRATION IS
SPILLING OVER ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE WALL.
>> WE MAY SOON HAVE ENOUGH TRASH
BUILDING UP TO BUILD A WALL.
IS THAT THE IDEA, MR. TRUMP?
WE COULD END THIS CRISIS TODAY.
21 DAYS IN IS TOO LONG.
THERE IS A SOLUTION.
THE SOLUTION INCLUDES, IT IS NOT
GOING TO BE YOUR WAY OR THE
HIGHWAY.
>> MIAMI INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT
IS CLOSING THE TERMINAL THIS
WEEKEND BECAUSE TSA SCREENERS
HAVE BEEN CALLING IN SICK AT A
HIGHER RATE.
THERE WON'T BE ENOUGH STAFFING
TO HANDLE ALL 11 CHECKPOINTS.
CHRIS VAN HOLLAND NOTED THAT THE
COAST GUARD TOLD EMPLOYEES A
GARAGE SALE COULD HELP COPE WITH
A SHUTDOWN.
>> WHEN THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES SAYS HE CAN
RELATE, I WANT TO SEE HIM HOLD A
GARAGE SALE.
>> Reporter: THERE ARE SOME
SIDES THAT BREAK FROM THE RANKS
WITH LISA MURKOWSKI WARNING IF
PRESIDENT TRUMP DECLARES A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY, IT COULD
LEAD TO FUTURE PROBLEMS.
>> WE DON'T KNOW WHO OUR NEXT
PRESIDENT MAY BE.
IT MAY BE A PRESIDENT WHOSE
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY IS DEALING
WITH CLIMATE CHANGE.
HE MAY SAY, I DON'T CARE WHETHER
I HAVE THE SUPPORT OF THE
CONGRESS.
ONE FRESHMAN DEMOCRAT SAID SHE
COULD VOTE IN SUPPORT OF A
BARRIER.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF IT IS STEEL.
I WILL VOTE FOR SOME MONEY FOR